je vous emmener ya quelques jours avec
moi à san francisco pour aller découvrir
le nouveau smartphone pliable de samsung
c'est le galaxy z flip
l'année dernière j'avais déjà parlé de
smartphones pliable avec le galaxy folz
samsung inox énormément dans ce domaine
là ça fait des années qu'ils travaillent
dessus là une année en eu une toute
première mouture qui était effectivement
un smartphone qui s'ouvrait pour devenir
une tablette et cette année c'est un
smartphone qui se rétrécit pour avoir un
format extrêmement petit extrêmement de
poche un format pocket ces le galaxy z
flip
alors on va regarder ce que fait ce que
les accises et de philips qui vous
permet de faire ça fait plusieurs jours
que je vais en main entre l'autre jour
on l'a découverte à san francisco et
puis je les ai reçus en entrant à paris
je lis avec moi depuis quelques jours je
le teste sous toutes les coutures sous
tous les angles et il est maintenant
temps de vous dire ce que je pense de ce
samsung galaxy z flip d'ailleurs dès
maintenant je demande de laisser un joli
pouce vole lui c'est pour l'algorithme
il faut que les vidéos de référence est
le fait de laisser des jolies pouces
c'est très important donc je les pousse
commentaires on s'abonne au lac
on envoie de l'amour et moi aussi je
vous envoie plein d'amour un smartphone
ça nous distinguer de quatre manières
différentes
lorsque vous allez dans le choisir vous
allez avoir d'abord toute la partie
multimédia lors la partie multimédia
ça recoupe plusieurs choses vous allez
avoir l'écran
vous allez également avoir la partie
audio l'expérience globale
lorsque vous allez regarder des films
des séries lorsque vous allez jouer à
des jeux toute la partie divertissement
et multimédia vous allez ensuite avant
la partie qui est double avec la
performance est bien évidemment toute la
question de l'autonomie
vous avez bien évidemment la partie du
design et puis bien évidemment un des
usages majeur aujourd'hui c'est toute la
partie photo vidéo mais surtout la
partie photo ça c'est notre ligne de
route pour tester ce smartphone galaxy z
flip est ce qu'il répond à ces quatre
usage on va noter de plusieurs manières
entre - - - ce qui est vraiment le
smartphone qui est dégueulasse - - bourg
est un moyen pas terrible - c'est assez
moyen plus c'est pas mal plus plus ça
c'est franchement bien et alors là le
top c'est plus plus plus plus les trois
plus ça c'est vraiment génial qu'on voit
donc tout de suite commencer par le
design ce qui est un des points le plus
important en tout cas mon avis l'une des
forces majeures sur ce smartphone le
galaxy sept fils sa smart phones qui
ressemble à aucun autre en un format qui
est extrêmement petit lorsqu'il est
replié
c'est effectivement le format pocket
vous qui dans une poche dans un sac à
main il est vraiment extrêmement fin et
lorsque vous allez venir
l'ouvrir vous allez découvrir un grand
smartphone avec un écran de 6 9 7 pouces
mais ça je vous en reparle dans quelques
instants
c'est tout l'adn de ce smartphone il se
plie il se cache il est vraiment tout
petit par contre si on arrive à regarder
un petit peu ce que je vais bien en face
il n'est pas complètement fermée voyez
on arrive à voir à travers c'est
peut-être un des défauts du galaxy fit
alors non pas des fautes design mais on
peut imaginer que effectivement et bien
vous pouvez toujours avoir des petites
cochonneries j'aime bien ce petit mot
des cochonneries qui peuvent se glisser
à l'intérieur
donc effectivement 10 que ferme et il va
revenir protéger l'écran mais attention
parce que des choses peuvent quand même
passé à l'intérieur et venir
potentiellement abîmer votre galaxy ses
deux filles
donc il faut faire gaffe fermé il ya
quand même venir protéger mais c'est pas
complètement parfait par contre moyens
truc avec ce smartphone rien n'arrête le
produit en lui-même c'est le nom je
n'arrive pas toujours galaxy z flip
alors à force on finit par s'y habituer
à force d'en parler mais bon voilà je
suis pas se passer complètement génial
après c'est vrai qu'il fait quand même
relativement le taf le format est tout
petit ici j'ai mis la coque de
protection qui fournit avec pour venir
vraiment le protéger parce que c'est pas
du tout un smartphone qui est protégé ni
contre la poussière ni contrôle ou alors
ça va pas empêcher la poussière de venir
néanmoins ça n'a quand même un petit peu
le le protéger alors il faut savoir
qu'une innovation qui a été fait de la
part de samsung au niveau de la
charnière
vous le verrez pas comme ça mais à
l'intérieur de la petite brosse vous
êtes trouvaient de chaque côté ce qui
fait que lorsque la poussière va
potentiellement devenir arrivée des
petits grains grain de sable et
compagnie eh bien il ya des brosses qui
vont empêcher que ça rentre alors je
pense effectivement c'est une première
protection mais c'est pas complètement
idéal donc vraiment fait vraiment
vraiment temps sur ce smartphone qui
n'est absolument pas résistant mis à
l'eau ni à la poussière si vous
l'emmener en vacances avec vous faites
vraiment ultra attention protéger le
mettez dans une poche plastique fermé si
vous emmener à la plage fait vraiment
extrêmement attention parce que ça à
1500 euros
oh c'est quand même de regretter de base
lorsque vous laissez le bouton de côté
appuyé c'est le bouton de bixby qui vous
permet d'avoir bixby lui parler lui
demander des choses et tout ce que vous
voulez mais si vous voulez pas bixby
s'est dit si ça vous intéresse
absolument pas vous pouvez venir
paramétrer ce bouton vous allez dans vos
paramètres dans fonctions avancées
touches latérales
soit vous avez activé avec un appui
prolongé bixby soit éteindre le
smartphone bon vous choisissez fait ce
que vous voulez personnellement il
utilise palix bits donc ça ça me va
parfaitement bien
de la même manière lorsque vous êtes un
smartphone fermé fait un double appui
sur le bouton principal
ça va venir vous activer la caméra alors
vous voyez vous avez votre petit écran
ici je vous en parlais un simple écran
de 1,06 pussy chrome notification qui
vous servira pas à grand chose si ce
n'est
à venir ça vous prend des petites photos
en mode raccourci extrêmement simplement
vous appuyez sur les boutons de volume
ensuite vous venez faire vos petites
photos bon pourquoi pas je trouve pas ça
complètement dingue à moi j'ai quand
même un peu un peu déçu un peu dubitatif
parce que vous savez autant sur le
galaxy fold on avait un écran
notification que je trouvais pas très
très grand par rapport à la surface
globale
là ils sont restés là dedans sauf une
toute petite baraque un petit écran
notification j'aurais pu avoir un sens à
ce qu'ils ne fassent un écran
notification un peu plus gros ici on
aurait pu faire un peu plus de choses
pas autant qu'à l'intérieur
mais on a pu aller un peu plus loin sa
rue un sens là cet écran il est vraiment
tout petit mise à part effectivement
voir leur votre niveau de charge voir un
petit peu la date voir les différentes
notifications répondre à un appel
extrêmement rapidement ou lira le début
d'un sms vous fait pas grand chose je
trouve que c'est extrêmement limité
c'est dommage parce qu'il aurait
probablement quelque chose à faire de
beaucoup plus intéressant ici l'écran
être là par contre extrêmement bien bien
maîtrisée des calibres et samsung très
très très fort dans les dalles de ses
smartphones ainsi à l'écran de 6,7
poussée du full hd ça d'écran dynamiques
amoled et surtout ce qui est assez
marrant c'est le format on a un ratio 22
9e c'est très très très longue c'est
extrêmement allongé moi sur ma vidéo
lâchement 18 9e et pourtant voyez des
grandes bordeaux entre chaque côté
forcément on est en 22 9e dont tu as
qu'il faut venir
zoomer dans l'image ça vient manger du
contenu et si vous avez une vidéo en
16/9 ça va être encore pire
à côté de ça l'expérience audio donc la
partie multimédia vous avez juste un
petit haut parleur sur le côté c'est un
haut parleur mono pour bar vous êtes sur
un smartphone très haut de gamme vous
n'avez pas de par leur taille aux est
sûre ça quand même dommage on sent ici
la petite pliure peux pas vous dire
qu'on la sent pas c'est pas vrai après
on oublie extrêmement rapidement moi ça
m'a pas du tout gêné lorsque j'allais
dire travail d'autant plus que je vais
surtout venir naviguer sur la partie du
bas la partie des objets pas
particulièrement l'habitude je suis pas
beaucoup sur la partie du centre donc ça
ne dérange pas mais je peux pas vous
dire qu'on la ressent pas c'est pas vrai
on la sent et on la voit légèrement
lorsque je viens de mettre comme ça mais
sa part gamme relativement normal vu que
c'est un smartphone qui explique samsung
a modifié sa physio route par rapport à
ce qu'ils ont fait sur le galaxy folle
c'est à dire pop là venez pas ici au
nouvel écran tout plastique avec un
toucher un peu plastique sous le doigt
et nous sommes ici un écran avec du
plastique mais également avec du verre
avec un verts extra-fins dessous ça
permet d'avoir touché un peu différent
que ce qu'on va retrouver sur le galaxy
folle mais on sent quand même le côté
plastique sait parler aux gens moi ça me
dérange absolument pas le seul tout ce
que ça va potentiellement de déranger
c'est que le plastique risque de marquer
donc si vous allez venir frotter avec un
nom vous allez laisser une marque et
cette marque
restera vous pourrez pas l'enlever donc
fait vraiment extrêmement attention
maintenant ce que je trouve marrant avec
son smartphone qu'on peut venir ouvrir à
une main dès lors vous êtes un petit peu
habile vous n'êtes glisser votre doigt
vous pousser et vous l'ouvrez une main
c'est pas ce qu'il ya de plus simple
c'est parce qu'être plus dingue mais ça
marche par an pour le refermer
c'est très très très très très facile
donc ça marche très très bien vous venez
à l'ouvrir voulait fermer la charnière
est bien parce qu'avec m résistante vers
l'autre ouvrir un petit peu tac vous
poussez s'est ouvert et un effet style
c'est czerniak donné par samsung pour
avoir 200 1000 cycles d'ouverture et de
fermeture c'est très compliqué j'ai pas
de machine pour venir l'ouvrir elle
ferme et 200 mille fois oui je peux le
faire un petit peu alors pour l'instant
j'ai pas trouvé de problème
gillett depuis une semaine donc ça me
paraît quand même relativement normal
mais je n'arrive pas à savoir si elle va
pouvoir emmener au bout des deux sens
mais cycle ou des cinq ans ils ont donné
par samsung
ça me paraît quand même résistance je ne
doute pas que le travail qui est fait en
conception et en industrialisation
derrière de la part de samsung soit
vraiment de bonne qualité parce que je
trouve rassurant c'est que voyez on n'a
pas l'impression que c'est une petite
charnière qui n'est pas sérieuse vous
venez la bouger comme ça bon bout d'un
mois que le mouvement forcément à
devenir bouger mais elle à différentes
positions pour venir s'arrêter
on sent qu'à une bonne conception une
conception très sérieuses faites de la
part de samsung au niveau de sa
charnière bien évidemment l'ol on est
sur un nuage 2 qui est vraiment bien qui
marche très très bien qui tourne sur un
android 10 et en plus à des petites
particularités qui ont été apportées qui
sont liées à l'usagé des smartphones
pliable et notamment vous allez dans
accessibilité vous allez dans
interactions et dextérité et vous allez
dans et vous allez dans répondre et
mettre fin aux appels
voyez en bas vous avez un truc qui est
assez intéressant par défaut cds cochet
vous avez juste de cocher fermeture
téléphone pour terminer donc lorsque
vous avez passé un appel vous formez
votre téléphone et tac vous avez
raccroché
mais ça s'arrête pas là lorsque vous
recevez un coup de fil vous pouvez
activer cette case ouverture du
téléphone pour répondre très très
simplement votre téléphone sonne
oublié le nom de la personne qui vous
appelle vous avez juste à le prendre à
l'ouvrir vous le mettez à votre oreille
et là vous êtes directement
communication donc si ac mais son ca
relativement marrant et c'est bien que
ça a été intégrée directement à l' os de
samsung autre chose qu'à traçantes et je
voulais déjà montré ça me saoule vous
l'avez montré lorsque les permis
d'entre-apercevoir le modem c'est
lorsque vous allez venir le plier comme
ça voyez vous avez la partie photo qui
vient se loger en haut vous rouvrez elle
revient en bas c'est un petit acte mais
c'est pas mal parce que ça va vraiment
dans les usages photos que je vais vous
montrer tout à l'heure un peu plus loin
dans la vidéo et au point qui est
marrant vous avez ici son côté votre
petite barre latérale pourrait venir
ouvrir ça vous permet d'avoir votre
multitâche dont pouvait venir visionner
une vidéo vous pouvez vous faire des
photos en même temps vous avez un vrai
multitâche coup c'est vraiment
intéressant parce que moi le multitâche
je sais pas si vous l'utilisez
d'ailleurs marqué le mot renvoie aux
commentaires moi j'utilise jamais le
multitâche et je trouve que là pour le
coup on peut vraiment l'utiliser de
façon intelligente
après il ya un point sur lequel moi je
suis un peu un peu tiède c'est le
processeur puisque vous avez on va lever
la tête parce que sinon on va casser le
cou voilà ça ne marche pas comme ça vous
n'avez pas un des derniers processeurs
vous avez pas le dernier exynos
normalement si vous suivez l'actualité
de 5 ce que vous savez que samsung
utilise ses propres processeurs et
notamment pour les derniers samsung
galaxy s 20 sauf pour le marché
nord-américain il utilise des puces de
qualcomm mais sinon ce sont des puces
exynos là que nenni ce n'est pas une
puce exynos et une puce qualcomm ce qui
marche très très bien d'ailleurs dans
l'absolu pourquoi pas mais on n'a pas le
dernier soc de qualcomm on n'a pas le
dernier
qualcomm 865 on à 855 plus c'est un peu
la 2me génération qui est sorti l'année
dernière plus orienté gaming à 1855 qui
était présenté décembre 2018 la décembre
2019 était présenté à 865 et au milieu
de l'année vous avez vu arriver le 855
plus qui améliore lui 855 mais qui ne va
pas aussi loin que ce que ferait 1 865 à
leur attention
on les gagne dans une des dernières
générations dans le soap extrêmement
récent un soft qui marche parfaitement
bien on n'est pas sûr du milieu de gamme
on est sur du haut de gamme
ça fonctionne c'est bien mais on aurait
pu s'attendre que sur un smartphone à
1500 euros on est ce qu'il ya de plus
puissant et là c'est pas le cas
à côté de ça on a fait beaucoup de
fluidité 8 gigas de ram ça marche et en
stockage aussi on est ce qu'il faut de
256 non extensible mais déjà que 256
giga vous ai vraiment de quoi faire mais
par contre hier résultat est là puisque
vous avez la note surtout de 474 1477
elles classent dans le top 5
en quatrième position juste entre le
readme x2 pro et le one + 7 pro on a
donc une machine extrêmement performante
qui marchent merveilleusement bien
qui dit format particulier dit aussi
particularités notamment au niveau de la
batterie puisque vous avez en tout et
pour tout une grosse batterie de trois
mille trois cent millions terreur mais
en fait c'est pas vrai vous n'avez pas
une grosse batterie de 3300 bien terrain
vous avez deux batteries à l'intérieur
une batterie de chaque hôtel dans le
global fait 3300 milliards erreurs mais
il ya eu vraiment un travail a été fait
au niveau de la fabrication même au
niveau de la conception même du
smartphone alors on pourrait se dire
3300 milliards eur pour un écran
d'ailleurs beecham oled de 6 7 pouces
c'est un peu short c'est pas un
smartphone qu'on va pouvoir garder deux
jours au niveau de l'autonomie c'est un
smartphone tout cas vous allez faire une
grosse journée dans la mesure où vous
n'êtes pas trop gourmand gros monde dans
la mesure où vous n'allez pas jouer
pendant des heures à mesure vous n'allez
pas faire énormément de photos de vidéos
partager beaucoup sont des réseaux
sociaux vous êtes garder une bonne
journée c'est un smartphone que vous
aller recharger tous les soirs avec un
chargeur de 15 watts qui fera le taf
mais qui n'est pas non plus le charger
le plus rapide
et qu'en est il maintenant de la partie
photo vous avez un double module caméra
avec deux fois 12 mégapixels vous avez
un 12 mégapixels
c'est un capteur principal c'est un
grand-angle qui ouvre à f 1.8 et vous
avez un deuxième capteur c'est un ultra
grand angle du bref 2.2 et qui servira
pour venir chercher effectivement des
très grands angles comme son nom
l'indiqué un petit flash led mais par
contre ici vous n'avez absolument pas de
télé objectifs tandis qu'à l'intérieur
vous avez une caméra de celle fille de
10 mégapixels alors je me suis posé la
question je me suis dit ok imaginons
imaginons c'est mon cas peut être votre
cas
imaginons g 1500 euros à mettre dans un
smartphone hors 1500 euros au jour
d'aujourd'hui peut-être que le prix de
ce smartphone va baisser mais imaginons
g 1500 euros à mettre dans un smartphone
je veux donc ce qui se fait de mieux et
notamment en termes de photos parce que
ça fait partie des usages et ici je n'ai
que je n'ai que j'ai déjà
mais je pourrais avoir plus j'ai un
double capteur photo aujourd'hui en 2020
et même c'était le cas en 2010 neuf ans
nous habituer sur les smartphones très
haut de gamme avant des triples ou du
photo capteur principal c'est un grand
en standard un deuxième capteur ultra
grand-angle pour vous dire capter des
choses que vous ne pourriez pas pour
dire élargir un peu pour me repousser
les murs ok ça marchait et puis un tel
objectif pour venir chercher un peu plus
loin
aujourd'hui le trip module photo c'est
un standard sur le trio de gamme donc
pourquoi est-ce que là-dessus samsung
noam uniquement un doublement des photos
sur un smartphone à 1500 euros mois dès
lors que j'ai de 1500 euros à m je me
posais la question je veux dire ok
l'idée du smartphone qui ce prix c'est
cool c'est sexy ça me permet de regarder
ce smartphone le dire est ce qu'au final
c'est ce produit là que je vais acheter
mais j'ai peur que ce soit un vrai frein
du fait de ne pas pouvoir faire autant
de choses en photo que ce que je
pourrais faire un smartphone qui va
coûter 200 à 300 euros de moins et sur
lequel j'aurai beaucoup plus de
performances ça c'est c'est quand même
bizarre des mots ce que vous en pensez
vous en bas en commentaire bon après les
modes de prise de vue sont vachement
intéressant au delà je voulais
effectivement d'avoir ce petit côté
logiciel qui est relativement marrant le
fait d'avoir
ce petit truc qui vous permettent
d'activer l'écran à l'avant bon voilà ça
c'est un peu rigolo mais surtout ce qui
va être sympa c'est que il fait quand
même très très très bien le taf et
surtout vous êtes un nouveau mode qui
vient d'arriver
mais ça je vous en parlerai dans mon
test des galaxy s 20 et notamment s20
ultra d'ici quelques jours
c'est le single take mode saas est
vraiment génial fait une petite vidéo de
quelques secondes et ça vous sort plein
de photos différentes des vidéos avec
des fils des essais des modes portrait
et ça c'est vraiment génial et ça je
vous en parle dans quelques jours donc
abonnez vous et vous saurez tout mais
voyez pas mal de possibilités mode vidéo
portrait mode portrait photo vidéo et
bien évidemment toutes les photos nues
et compagnie on a tout ce qu'on va
retrouver dans les smartphones haut de
gamme du point de vue purement
logicielle mais il faut comme ça pouvait
venir zoomer parce que même ce n'est pas
de zoom optique vous avez un zoom
numérique
vous venez un petit peu zoomer regardez
vous l'avez en bas vous choisissez x 2 x
4 x 8 tu veux montrer résultats il ya
des choses bien et d'autres un petit peu
moins lorsque vous allez venir faire des
photos vous voyez quand même vous avez
un résultat qui est assez rigolo alors
c'est très très saturé par rapport à ce
qu'on peut trouver je dirais 20 sont un
petit peu standard mais le résultat est
pas mal le dga du détail quand même là
je les passe en ultra grand-angle le
point s'est pas fait là il s'est fait
sur le côté petite statue caméra normale
c'est vraiment bien sûr que les coureurs
sont jolies c'est très saturé une faute
plus mais ça c'est vraiment propre à
samsung
ça fait vraiment le boulot on passe sur
l'ultra grand temps pareil caméra
principale il ya du détail vraiment au
niveau du ciel donc ça c'est bien il ya
un très très beau rendu rien et cramer
donc une très très belle gestion de la
plage dynamique ultra grand-angle ça
fait aussi relativement le taf caméra
principal foyer le ciel comme il est
bleu là c'est vraiment la saturation
ultra-grand-angle on vient où mais x 2 x
4 x 8 et là il ya quand même beaucoup de
bruit ce qui n'est pas normal vu coller
sur un zoom numérique caméra principale
ultra-grand-angle x 2 x 4 x 8 là on est
sur des photos une nuit alors photos de
nuit s'est pas complètement ouf
au niveau de la gestion des lumières
mais bon résultat quand même pas trop
mal l'ultra grand angle est tout de
suite beaucoup moins qualitative pour
tourner en extérieur en plein jour
caméra principale ultra-grand-angle x 2
x 4 x 8 voyage ce n'est pas grand chose
vous arrivez au frais 8 ans permet de
voir mais c'est pas terrible de la même
manière ici ça vient dénaturer s'est pas
complètement dingue voilà il faut lui
permet d'avoir de quelques petits
détails mais bon fois rendu est pas
génial qu'est ce qu'on peut faire avec
ce smartphone parce qu'effectivement le
vent faire tout ce qu'on peut faire
agréer smartphone un petit peu classique
on peut regarder l'écran on peut le
faire en grand
petit la mettre dans la poche tout ce
que je vous ai montré mais en fait ça
montre d'autres choses d'autres usages
qui sont propres à ce smartphone est
qu'on peut faire uniquement avec ce
smartphone j'en profite d'être là j'ai
un invité mystère qui est juste là
s'appelle elliott assez elliott qui est
juste là c'est la petite voix qui vous
passe le message en début de vidéo
alors justement on va se regarder un peu
les différents usages et vous allez voir
que c'est quand même super intéressant
vous avez différents usages que le
smartphone soit pliée soit entre ouvert
comme ça ou soit carrément ouvert comme
ça ou alors très très ouverts comme ça
alors je vous cache pas que si vous le
mettez comme ça vous allez pouvoir faire
des parties de château de cartes
mesquine ont globalement fait pas grand
chose un peu de décoration chez vous
c'est quand même dommage de mettre mes
500 euros pour avoir un objet décoratif
corgan a bien qu'ils le font usage
principal c'est vous allez le maître
comme çà et là par contre de suite vous
avez un réel intérêt
le premier intérêt pour moi c'est la
prise de photos vous positionnez votre
smartphone vous pouvez vous mettre vous
de l'autre côté vous ouvrez la main il
va reconnaître votre main et il va venir
faire une photo ça vous permet également
de vous prendre en self y voyez comme ça
vous ouvrez la main oh la la il
reconnaît la main et il déclenche la
photo ils vouvoient tac je me vois sur
la photo et là il ya un vrai usages et
là il ya un vrai intérêt
vous avez ensuite un autre usage que ce
que vous allez faire des photos de nuit
parce que le problème des photos nues
c'est souvent faut bouger leur avec mon
cas je raconte même pas l'histoire
lavaud smartphone vous le posez comme ça
pourrait faire des photos de nuit en
ultra grand-angle vous mettez comme ça
vous allez d'ennui alors ici fait
extrêmement jour vous mettez en ultra
grand temps ça vous fait un trépied et
ça c'est vraiment génial parce que voyez
c'est l'usagé des smartphones alors
attention elle surface sur laquelle vous
allez le poser surtout si vous ne
protégez pas parce que vous risquez tout
de suite devenir le rayer en bas de la
même manière pour faire des siennes fine
nuit vous le positionner face aux
photographes voyez ça c'est vraiment
cool ça vous permet également sauvé dans
une application type whatsapp ou
équivalentes est bien de faire de la
visioconférence en ayant les mains
libres vous posez votre smartphone
pouvait venir parler travailler ça vous
évite devenir le caler contre un livre
ou d'utiliser un petit trépied ou ce que
vous voulez vous le posez comme ça sur
la table et vous pouvez venir ensuite et
bien faire ce que vous voulez puisque
vous avez les mains les bras donc ça
c'est cool
l'autre point qui est intéressant c'est
le visionnage de films vous vous
positionnez comme ça vous vous mettez en
grand écran
alors soit on peut venir d regarde une
vidéo comme ça ce qui peut avoir un sens
mais je vous cache pas quand même que
c'est pas terrible
parce que voyez vraiment la pliure ça
vient des formes un peu ce que vous
allez regarder mais bon on peut faire
attention c'est quand même une limite
pas ce qui arrive un moment où à bout
et ça tombe par contre c'est beaucoup
mieux si vous le mettez comme ça ça va
être un peu plus difficile de venir
regarder un film ou une série comme ça
puisque vous avez un visionnage qui est
très très faim tout petit c'est parce
qu'être plus confort ça peut le faire
mais bon c'est pas idéal
il ya un autre point qui par contre est
assez marrant c'est que vous venez hop
vous décalez ici je sais pas moi on peut
dire par exemple que ben tiens je vais
venir ou vraiment calendrier et là j'ai
un vrai multitâche avec sans la partie
du haut ma vidéo que je peux venir
regarder si je le souhaite venir
naviguer ce crowley je peux faire ce que
je veux et pourquoi pas même une visio
compte et en bas je vais avoir mon
agenda ma prise de notes ça me permet de
travailler afin voyez il ya plein
d'usagé je trouve que beaucoup le
multitâche un vrai intérêt sur ce
smartphone lent et ça c'est vraiment
bien et lorsqu'il est déplié je dirais
que le vrai grand usage alors c'est pas
le multitâche pourrait avoir aussi du
multitâche comme ça si vous le souhaitez
pourquoi pas une fois de plus sur un
côté un peu visio conflit peut être
rigolo il peut y avoir un intérêt c'est
parce qu'il va paraître le plus évident
mais bon pourquoi pas et puis avoir
effectivement ce que les développeurs
vont pouvoir faire de cette idée
multitâche probablement des choses assez
intéressantes ce qui est de muscade de
venir regarder du contenu multimédia
comme ça avec un très très grand écran
ça c'est génial que ce soit ce côté
visionnage ou ce côté gaming même
pourquoi pas une fois de plus dans grand
univers du multimédia pour la danse
comme je vous le disais c'est un point
extrêmement important pour moi sur ce
smartphone c'est qu'il n'est absolument
pas étanche vous n'avez aucune
certification de par le côté
effectivement pliable de par le côté
technologique
ça peut être regrettable c'est un truc
qui peut être embêtant sur un smartphone
à 1500 euros
faites attention c'est bien marqué
lorsque vous l'ouvrez vous invite à
vivre mon deuil boxing si vous l'avez
pas vu c'est vraiment marqué noir sur
blanc par samsung
attention ne pas le mettre en contact
avec de l'eau avec de la poussière à +5
en a partout alors évitez de le mettre
par terre de laisser traîner pour que
les impuretés rentrer mais je dirais que
vous avez acheté un smartphone de ce
prix là 1500 euros c'est pas pour
l'utiliser un an et puis voilà c'est
pour utiliser deux ans voir un petit peu
plus si possible
c'est toujours un peu le truc je suis un
peu dubitatif est ce que le côté
brossette intérieure va vraiment faire
le boulot pour éviter que les
cochonneries rentrer ou pas il ya eu des
tests sur internet qui montrent qu'on
avait quand même quelques unes qui passe
c'est sûr que ça fait le taff quand même
en évitant que le gros rentrer mais
n'allez pas chercher les histoires
n'allait pas et met en contact avec des
particules extrêmement fines n'allait
pas l'emmener à la plage ou je ne sais
quoi encore ça pourrait être dommageable
aux pointes ou de regret sur ce
smartphone c'est qu'il n'est pas du tout
5 g compatible vous n'avez pas un modem
5 juin derrière vous ne pourrez donc pas
capter la 5g s'est pas immédiatement
extrêmement grave puisque la 5g commence
à se déployer en france à elle pense je
sais pas dans quel pays vous êtes
d'ailleurs marqué le mois en bas en
commentaires ou est-ce que vous habitez
et est ce qui est de la 5g chez vous et
si oui est-ce que vous avez déjà un
abonnement 5 g je pense pas que tout de
suite là début 2020 ça pose problème
mais ce smartphone il est voué en tout
cas être commercialisé pendant un an
deux ans avant d'être probablement
remplacé donc c'est quand même dommage
qu'il n'y ait pas de modem 5 g intérieur
une fois de plus sur un produit à 1500
euros
début 2000 20 pour 20 donc un autre
petit graphe avec nos différentes
catégories pour la partie multimédia
c'est à dire la partie écran et audio
moi je trouve que le rendu est pas mal
l'écran est pas mal la piqûre ça me
dérange pas trop
l'audio est un peu moyen mais dans
l'absolu l'expérience c'est quand même
pas mal et notamment bras côté pliable
donc je lui mets de plus l'autonomie est
assez moyenne
mais malgré tout n'est pas vraiment
c'est quand même au rendez vous je lui
mets de plus mais vraiment handicapé par
la partie autonomie la partie design
pour moi c'est vraiment le point fort du
smartphone c'est vraiment quelque chose
de très nouveau très novateur qu'on aime
ou qu'on aime pas il ya un design très
atypique et si on va dessus c'est qu'on
les aime pour moi je mets trois plus
personnellement j'adore
maintenant la partie photo ja trouve
bien mais elle n'est pas complètement
dingue ce qui est en place et très bien
maîtrisée mais il manque des choses pour
nous à 1500 euros
le fait qu'ils aient raté l'objectif par
rapport à ce que la concurrence c'est
handicapant donc voyez on n'a pas la
note maximale on pourrait attendre sur
un smartphone comme ça à voir la note
maximale et pourquoi est ce qu'on n'a
pas la note maximale parce que ce
smartphone coûte 1500 9 euros et qu'un
1509 euros on s'attend vraiment à voir
ce qui s'est mieux dans tous les
domaines pour conclure je dirais que
j'aime beaucoup
le galaxy fleet y z flip j'ai du mal
avec les noms j'aime beaucoup le galaxy
z flynn j'aime beaucoup moins son nom
j'aime beaucoup la proposition de valeur
qui fait derrière j'aime beaucoup cette
idée du smartphone qui se plie j'aime
beaucoup l'idée de l'écran pillards qui
apporte un nouveau
visage je pense que c'est une v1 et
comme tout les vins lé perfectionna bhl
il ya des choses qui peuvent être
vraiment améliorer les usages par contre
sont là je pense en avoir de plus en
plus je pense qu'on est qu'au début des
smartphones qui explique les écrans
pliables apporte beaucoup de fraîcheur
beaucoup de nouveautés beaucoup d' usage
beaucoup de choses qu'on n'avait pas
forcément depuis quelques années dans
les smartphones et ça je me sens
vraiment bien et rien que pour ça je
mettrai gros pouce bleus à samsung qui
innove qui montre en tout cas là où on
peut aller en terme de techno ce qu'on
peut faire et même si le smartphone ne
correspond pas je dirais à ce que moi je
rechercherai à 100% sur un centre de ce
prix là et bien néanmoins ça reste un
très joli produit et si vous voulez une
belle innovation un produit qui est
quand même très bon en termes de photos
les performances sont là l'autonomie est
un peu moyenne mais ça fait quand même
relativement le boulot on a un très beau
produit très innovant
moi j'aime beaucoup rien que pour ça je
trouve vraiment bien évidement vous ce
que vous en pensez maintenant en bas en
commentaire comment vous trouvez ce
samsung galaxy z flip non un petit peu
rallonge est ce qu'il vous plaît
est ce que vous pourriez potentiellement
l'acheter si vous l'avez déjà fait dites
moi ce que vous en pensez
en attendant ces deux smartphones vous
intéresse nous a mis tous les liens en
bas dans la description je vous invite
bien évidemment à vous abonner
parce qu'on va continuer à parler des
clous la plaine va se raconter sur sera
donné le mot de la fin à elliott
d'elliot qu'est ce qu'on dit events and
the papas sinon gare à toi là j'adore ça
c'est debout la fin à demain
à vous
m
ces bolides la bouder
[Musique]